freshman congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez accuses fellow woman Kellyanne
Conway of being sexist toward her
because quote the patriarchy has no
gender we will examine why AOC is wrong
about gender patriarchy and everything
else then
Sacre star Megan Rapinoe agrees with her
conservative critics about equal pay and
a judge rules that President Trump can't
block people on Twitter all that more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
okay before we get to the sex that I
want to talk about which is the sexism
and the gender and the patriarchy we
have to talk about the sex that I don't
want to talk about which is this sordid
saga of Jeffrey Epstein because I you
know how much I hate to point out that I
told you so yesterday on the show I
mentioned that the left would be framing
this as an anti-trump issue that this is
all about Donald Trump I just want to
point out that the major Washington Post
coverage on this today this is the
headline quote Jeffrey Epstein was a
terrific guy
Trump once said now he's not a fan no
headline about Bill Clinton no headline
about the really shady bizarre past of
Jeffrey Epstein no headline about that
no no it's just all about Trump which is
the only reason they're bringing this up
now and I just want to on this one point
where they keep going back to this 2002
New York magazine article where Donald
Trump called Epstein a terrific guy I
just want to remind everybody that
Donald Trump regularly calls awful
people terrific guys this is just I
guess his way of speaking Hills
you know if it's convenient he'll say oh
yeah him he's terrific oh I really like
that guy even if he's the worst guy on
earth he actually has done it about the
worst guy on earth back when he started
opening negotiations with North Korea he
used the exact same word to refer to Kim
jong-un here's President Trump
what making tremendous progress chairman
Kim has been really very open and
terrific frankly so we know this is just
the way that President Trump talks
especially when he's flattering people I
mean Trump historically has been a
flatterer
he'll flatter people and then the minute
they turn on him he'll call them the
worst names you can possibly imagine
this has been true of Rosie O'Donnell
this has been true of everybody else
that he's encountered I also want to
point out there is a lot of weird stuff
with this epstein story it seems like
every hour we're getting new information
that complicates the picture and there
are some pretty wild
theories swirling around I'm not going
to call them conspiracy theories because
I guess they could be true but I'm not
going to say that they're obvious facts
because we just really have no idea
what's going on here but the big
question that keeps popping up is how
did Jeffrey Epstein make all his money
because Jeffrey Epstein isn't just rich
Jeffrey Epstein is really really really
rich Jeffrey Epstein in 1992 had the
largest private residence in Manhattan
Manhattan is the center of the world
Manhattan is the most primo real estate
on earth basically an Epstein had the
single largest private residence on the
whole island there's rich and then
there's really rich and then there is
unfathomably infinite resources rich and
Epstein falls into that last category
and the question you have to ask is how
the guy's a college dropout I guess he
was at the Cooper Union which is an art
school art and engineering he dropped
out of it
he then this is a kind of a weird
coincidence he was hired to teach at a
private school a very prestigious
private school in New York actually not
far from where I grew up he was hired
there by Attorney General William bars
father Donald Bar and he taught there
for a little bit and then he left then
he worked at Bear Stearns
the financial firm which went under this
became a big part of the financial
crisis in 2007-2008 then he left under
pretty shady circumstances we don't know
why he left we don't know how he did
there and he started his own hedge fund
and then he ostensibly became this
incredibly wealthy guy I know people who
have worked for hedge funds and who have
their own hedge funds I'm a lot of them
have made an insane amount of money but
it's also worth remembering most hedge
funds fail it's not like I mean it hedge
fund even that term is so vague and so a
lot of people at the time were wondering
how where did Epstein get his money from
is he just the greatest investor in
world I mean who are his clients he kept
his clients to be a tightly held secret
we just don't really know anything about
that guy and it gets even weirder
because now today from The Daily Beast
there's a report in about why now labor
secretary Alexander Acosta who was then
a US attorney let Epstein off the hook
with this sweetheart deal instead of
sending him away for life for all of the
charges against him he got 13 months in
a private wing of a county jail and
that's it and he got to leave six days a
week for 12 hours a day how did he get
that deal and this is what The Daily
Beast is reporting quote is the Epstein
case going to be a problem for
confirmation hearings Acosta had been
asked Acosta had explained breezily
apparently that back in the day he'd had
just one meeting on the Epstein case
he'd cut the non-prosecution deal with
one of Epstein's attorneys because he
had been told in quotes to back off that
Epstein was above his pay grade quote I
was told Epstein belonged to
intelligence and to leave it alone he
told his interviewers in the Trump
transition who evidently thought that
that was a sufficient answer and went
ahead and hired Acosta the Labor
Department had no comment when asked
about this this is the stuff of
conspiracy theory I mean this except
it's being reported by The Daily Beast
which occasionally is a sort of
mainstream outlet you know it's not like
this is one of these really fringy sites
as far as left-wing outlets go Daily
Beast is about as mainstream as they get
now Before we jump to the conclusion
that this is all some secret plot by the
CIA or intelligence or whatever it is
possible that Acosta was just coming up
with an excuse to explain why he bungled
the deal with Jeffrey Epstein
I guess that's possible before we
conclude that this is some crazy CIA
plot to I don't know to have a sex ring
or to entrap very powerful men it's also
possible that they were using that the
intelligence community was using Jeffrey
Epstein as an asset for other purposes
maybe in the financial crisis maybe I
mean the financial crisis was happening
as this deal was struck maybe he was
useful to them in the collapse of Bear
Stearns maybe he was you
to them for other purposes we just don't
know we don't know anything about this
guy and so the the theories are swirling
around there is one theory that the the
person backing Epstein isn't a person at
all it wasn't just this cabal of you
know zillion errors who all happened to
like 13 year old girls or 14 year old
girls one theory that Ann Coulter
brought up yesterday is that he could
have had a state sponsor that this was a
state-sponsored intelligence operation
I'm not saying that's what it was I have
absolutely no idea nobody else does
either but the question of how Jeffrey
Epstein made his money who was funding
him in the first place is going to be
central to to the rest of this case and
so well obviously we'll be following
this as as it builds now to get to the
sex that I want to talk about the sex
that I want to talk about is AOC
accusing Kellyanne Conway of being
sexist toward her now you might have
heard you heard that name Kelly Anne
that's a woman's name
so AOC also a woman is saying that Kelly
Ann a woman is sexist toward a woman the
reason why is that Kelly Ann Conway on
Fox News referred to the recent tiff
between Nancy Pelosi and AOC as a
catfight here's Kelly Ann there was four
female Democrats that Nancy Pelosi is
those is brushing back I think they're
all freshman members a major meow moment
brushing back in a huge catfight really
ridiculing them and they voted against
the Democratic aid package meow indeed
ooh it was a catfight that's not a
sexist term that's an accurate
description this was a particularly
snarky battle that was going on between
especially Nancy Pelosi and and to AOC
here is how AOC described it quote
catfight is a sexist term Republicans
use when two adult women happen to
disagree with each other the reason they
find it's so novel and exciting is
because the GOP haven't elected enough
women themselves to see that in fact
can be a normal occurrence in a
functioning democracy meanwhile the GOP
nominated a woman for Vice President
2008 woman one of our leading future
presidential candidates is nikki Haley
you former UN Ambassador governor of
South Carolina I mean you could go down
the list the GOP has a ton of women and
of course Kellyanne Conway a V campaign
manager for Donald Trump for a
successful campaign a female campaign
manager in American history and a senior
adviser to the president so I don't
think that it makes a whole lot of sense
but catfight isn't just a term used by
Republicans it's a term that everybody
uses to describe when two women are
getting angry with each other I mean you
could you could say a fight between two
men is a bunch of knuckle draggers or a
couple of Neanderthals you hear those
kind of terms as well but then a OC gets
to her main point and this exposes the
lie of the entire gender ideology
movement we'll get to that in a second
but first because I know what time it is
I know we've got to thank our sponsors
over at movement you know how much I
love movement watches I wear it all the
time I get compliments on it all the
time I've never gotten more compliments
on a watch than I have on this one and I
think this is the coolest watch they
have although they have many cool
watches this is the revolver collection
the Atlas version of it I just love this
thing because these guys these two
college dropouts who started this watch
company just get modern style I mean
their watches they're not just totally
futuristic they've they drawn so much of
the past on those great watch errors in
1950s 1960s but then they update them so
that it's not just rehashing something
old they're new they're sleek they're
just fabulous now they have mechanical
watches they have an automatic watch the
arc design which I love I don't have it
yet but I really want it if anyone's
listening out there they're just
terrific a terrific product and the best
part of it is as far as I'm concerned if
you went into a department store they'd
be three four hundred dollars if you you
order it online I mean because movement
cuts out the middleman you can save so
much money you can save you know you're
getting direct
and especially for summer you love their
watches their sunglasses are fabulous
they they make a very fun statement like
the 90s skinny frames they've got
everything they've got them all movement
sunglasses have the same advantage they
start at just 60 bucks no pair prices
over $95 so you're guaranteed to find a
style that you love with quality that
doesn't break the bank they've sold over
two and a half million products in more
than 160 countries the collections are
always expanding you've trusted them on
their watches you've got to trust them
on their sunglasses they just get style
get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com slash
knowles cy movement keeps growing check
out their expanding collection
MVM t.com / Knowles Kino wles
join the movement so then a OC follows
this up and she gets to the actual point
here that dissolves I think the
transgender ideology and she says
patriarchy has no gender this is how she
explains how a woman can be sexist
against another woman she says
patriarchy has no gender now just as a
simple point of definitions I went to
the Oxford English Dictionary I thought
maybe I'm wrong about the definition of
patriarchy no it turns out a OC is wrong
patriarchy as defined by the OED is
quote a system of society or government
in which the father or eldest male is
head of the family and descent is
reckoned through the male line father
nail okay that's that's patriarchy it
does have a gender so on the surface a
o'seas comment doesn't make any sense on
the surface the gender ideology
transgender ideology movement doesn't
make any sense
but there actually is sort of almost an
internal logic to it and conservatives
totally mistake had a deal with gender
ideology and transgenderism we make the
mistake of trying to argue this point on
scientific grounds this is what you
always hear let's just talk about the
science forget religion forget morals
forget philosophy we just want to talk
about the science
or the chromosomes or the biology or
whatever I know that's tempting because
we're scientifically our points are
correct but gender is not a scientific
concept the way that the left is talking
about gender the way that aoc is talking
about gender and patriarchy is not
scientific gender is not a scientific
term gender was was a term that was
never applied to human beings
in popular culture until about the 1960s
gender was a term that was applied to
language you have gendered language
really not so much in English but in
other languages so for instance Latino
has a masculine gender latina has a
feminine gender pizza the Italian word
pizza it ends in an A and it's got a
female gender but I don't know Quran so
which is the Italian word for lunch that
ends in an O and it's got a male gender
the gender is a language term the entire
purpose of the left making gender into a
description of people is to undermine
science it's it's to separate sex from
gender you hear this all the time I talk
to conservatives all the time on
campuses around the country and I think
even many conservatives believe this
they believe that there is a difference
between sex and gender I mean in their
defense this is what they're taught in
classrooms this is what kids are now
taught from kindergarten all the way
through college or graduate school the
thing is there is no difference between
sex and gender you can lock that away
with the Easter Bunny and the Tooth
Fairy sex and gender have no difference
we just have sex and I can prove it to
you I can give you the argument you can
you can use to show this to any leftist
I can do that in a second but first we
have got to thank another sponsor ring
you know how ring makes neighborhoods
safer I've told you about their smart
video doorbells and their cameras that
protect millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery if there's a surprise
visitor either a burglar or your
mother-in-law
whichever one
worse you will get an alert you will be
able to see here and speak to them all
from your phone and that's thanks to the
HD video and two-way audio features on
ring devices our senior producer Jay Hey
was in his house this was a few months
ago at this point lying there with this
lovely wife 3 o'clock in the morning and
he gets an alert on his phone see
someone's at the door it sees two
drug-addled weirdos who they JK lives in
a kind of remote part of town
they didn't just happen to be walking
down the street they were casing the
joint they wanted to break in they
wanted to see if anybody was home he
picks up he says what are you doing at
my house they come up with some weird
lame excuse there stammering then they
run away now Jay hey was home in his bed
that's where he answered that from he
could have been at the office he could
have been on a beach somewhere it
doesn't matter you have access to your
home from anywhere it's an amazing
product not only cuz it makes you safer
not only because it's like neighborhood
watch for the 21st century but because
you will feel like the Jetsons I mean
that's what I love about it that's why I
feel safe with a ring is I feel like I'm
just living in the future you know and I
whenever my friends get a new house
whenever they move into a new place my
housewarming gift is always ring part of
the reason for that too
is it's an amazing value it's a great
deal I don't need to spend zillion
dollars I'm getting them a housewarming
gift I can give them a ring I know
they're gonna feel cool and they're
gonna feel safe as a listener you have a
special offer on a ring starter kit
available right now with a video
doorbell and motion-activated floodlight
camera the starter kit has everything
you need to start building a ring of
security around your home get it today
here's how you do it ring.com
/ Knowles kayo wles ring.com / Knowles
so even conservatives fall into this
trap we by the leftist premise that
there's a difference between gender and
sex or if we don't maybe we don't want
to grant that premise but we try to
argue about it scientifically there is
no scientific argument for it here is
how I've talked to so many left wingers
about this they can never answer the
ultimate questions here's how the
argument goes this is what the left says
they say sex is biological
gender is not biological it's a social
construct it's psychological it's not
physical it's not the same as sex but if
gender is just a social construct if
it's just sort of a choice then people
should choose to make their gender
conform to their biological sex right if
you can just kind of choose your gender
and it's just a matter of your personal
will then if you're biologically a man
but you identify as a female and that's
just a choice then you should just
choose to identify as a male that's
that's much easier than going through
all this awful surgery mutilating
yourself changing every single bathroom
in the country right of course but then
what the gender ideologues will say is
it's not quite like that sex is in the
body and you know the chromosomes or the
genitals or whatever but gender is in
the brain okay and you can't change your
brain well okay except then that means
that gender is biological then they're
then it's not a difference of biological
and not biological because of the brain
is the part of the body the brain is
probably the most important part of the
body so then you have to conclude sex
and gender are both biological so how
can your biology be both male and female
how can your biology be both you are a
man and a woman except in the
exceedingly rare case where there's some
confusion in chromosomes or in in
genitals which is not what transgender
ideologue Zoar talking about how can it
be both one thing and not that thing so
this is what they're coming around to
now this is the new stage of gender
ideology and it's where you hear phrases
like biologically female penises I had a
gender activist tell me once at the
University of Michigan
she said yes of course there can be
biologically female penises and of
course there can be biologically male
uteruses biological see because they
want the language of science but if that
is the case then the words male and
female the words man and woman have no
meaning because they can because the
word male
in that case can refer to either male or
female the word man can refer to either
man or woman and vice versa they don't
it's it's not that you're even changing
the definition of the word so much as
you're just getting rid of the words
altogether now they get very confused on
this and they always run away and they
they can't answer these questions but I
actually see what they're trying to talk
about what the gender theory people are
trying to describe is not a scientific
characteristic of people they're trying
to describe the soul they're they're
trying to describe the difference
between my physical body and my
metaphysical soul so what the
transgender ideologue says on the
physical level I look like a man you
know I got broad shoulders I got a beard
I've got everything below the waist that
makes me look like a man but at a more
essential level deep deep down somewhere
that you can't see I'm not really what
my body says that I am I'm something
else there's a difference they say
between me and my body and this is not a
totally new question and when we think
of transgenderism is this bizarre new
idea it's just a bizarre new version of
a very old idea this is the central
question of the gender theory this is
the central problem is is as a question
as all this time what is the
relationship between me and my body and
my soul and this question took on
special modern significance with Rene
Descartes with the the father of modern
philosophy who laid the foundation for
the Enlightenment and who consequently
gave us a lot of our modern problems
what Descartes said is that the body is
not essential to a person's identity so
my body you know I've got sort of
swarthy skin I've got a little bit of a
Roman nose I've got some poofy hair that
is not essential to my identity that's
just sort of accidental what I really am
is immaterial I my body exists as a
machine and then my soul which is who I
really am
exists as a ghost in that machine now I
don't really believe that that
what a lot of modern people think that's
what Descartes thought and that's what
these gender ideologue believed but this
isn't the traditional understanding the
traditional understanding of the body
the Christian understanding Aristotle's
understanding Thomas Aquinas is
understanding is that the body is
essential to a person's identity now
there are a lot of weird theories that
have popped up throughout history to say
that the physical world is evil the
physical body is evil matter is evil and
therefore we should divorce ourselves
from the material world this has cropped
up as a number of bizarre movements and
heresies and things like that those
ideas have always been defeated because
civilization would collapse if we really
believes them if we really believe that
everything physical is just evil and
terrible and awful and has to be utterly
rejected you can't have a civilization
you can't have a society you can't even
move around in your own body but that's
what the gender theory people believe
they're searching for a soul but they
can't bring themselves to admit that
because they also tend to believe that
there's no such thing as a soul so
they're stuck in this awful place where
they're arguing the extremes of two
ideologies both of which are completely
wrong I think I know how we can deal
with this I think I know how we can talk
to people about the gender ideology that
isn't just look at the chromosomes look
at the science because I think
ultimately that doesn't really go
anywhere we'll get to how to deal with
them in a second we will also get to
Megan Rapinoe I guess it must be a
chilly day in hell because I'm actually
agreeing with the soccer star on one
question and then we'll also get to why
President Trump can't block people on
Twitter but first you've got to go to
Daley wire.com it is ten bucks a month
100 dollars for an annual membership you
get me you get the Andrew Clavin show
you get the Ben Shapiro show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag you get the
Matt Walsh show you get another Kingdom
you get all of these wonderful things by
the way get your mailbag questions in
for tomorrow but you get the leftist
here's tumblr and you are gonna need
that leftist tears tumblr because as the
Jeffrey Epstein case starts unveiling
exposing all of these powerful
Democratic men
perhaps including a former Democratic
president that the tumbler you're gonna
drown you're going to be flooded out and
drown if you don't have the tumbler so
go to daily wire comm we'll be right
back with a lot more
so the gender theory people are trying
to describe the soul except they don't
believe in the soul because they tend to
be materialists they tend to think that
only the physical world exists and all
of the things that aren't physical like
love and joy and the soul and that it's
all basically just an illusion that
we're just matter we're just kind of
flesh and that that's all that we are so
they distinguish between the physical
body sex and the metaphysical mind or
gender but then they go right back and
they deny the difference between the
mind which is not physical and the brain
which is physical and so you you get to
this contradiction any way you slice it
gender ideology doesn't make sense but
we are very foolish if we think that
we're gonna convince them of that based
on science it's not a scientific
question it's a philosophical and
religious question and at times
throughout history when people have been
philosophically and religiously shallow
and stupid these kind of theories crop
up the foundation for gender theory was
laid by two things the decay of
education and the decay of religion and
we are now seeing the fruits of that
because people just don't they have
these really shallow ideas I mean dr.
Johnson famously said all shallows are
clear little shallow bodies of water
very clear profound things are murky you
can't see to the bottom of profound
things and we have a very shallow
religious and educational culture right
now which is why these gender people are
so convinced that they're correct even
though they're they couldn't possibly be
more confused you're not going to be
able to just convince people that gender
ideology is wrong with a simple argument
you're gonna have to slowly build on
that you're gonna have to raise serious
religious questions raise serious
philosophical questions you're gonna
have to rebuild the educational system
you're gonna have to start going back to
church or synagogue or wherever you go
you're going to have to start taking
these things seriously because if
conservatives just keep up this look at
the science argument you're not going to
convince anybody it's not a
out science it's about something that
much deeper and something that we've
lost and we know as conservatives you
can't just shout from the rooftop of a
you actually have to do the thing you
can't just talk about how great religion
is you actually up to practice it you
can't just talk about how great certain
education systems are you have to do
them you have to read the books and you
have to make it a big part of your life
so I bizarrely I can't believe I'm
saying this I actually sort of agree
with aoc that the patriarchy has no
gender because nobody has a gender
because people don't have genders we
have sex it's all about sex baby and in
other bizarro world news I'm also
finding myself agreeing with the u.s.
women's soccer star Megan Rapinoe also
on a question of sex
Megan Rapinoe was on my MSNBC show last
night and she was there to discuss her
calls for equal pay for the men's and
women's soccer teams and she
accidentally I think but nevertheless
she agreed with the arguments of her
conservative critics here's Megan
Rapinoe in the moments immediately
following the final whistle you get that
USA USA chant but equal pay equal pay
along that same cadence yet I think fans
want to know what they can do to support
that fight fans can come to games
obviously the national team games will
be a hot ticket but we have nine teams
in NWSL you can go to your League games
you can support that way you can you
know buy players jerseys you can lend
your support in that way you can tell
your friends about it you can become
season ticket holders I think in terms
of of that that's the the easiest way
for for fans to get involved she's
totally right about this the issue of
equal pay for the men's and women's
soccer teams is not a question of some
regulation or some law or some secret
hidden institutional patriarchy it's a
question of revenue Matt Walsh had a
great point on this yesterday it's not
just that women's soccer players are
underpaid or they're paid less than men
they are paid less than men as a matter
of just numbers but as a matter you know
a hard cash as a matter of the
percentage of their business that
they're paid when
soccer players are actually overpaid and
the reason for that is just to cite a
few statistics here the Men's World Cup
generated six billion dollars in revenue
that was the last World Cup six billion
with a big the Women's World Cup
generated can you guess
131 million dollars of revenue way way
way less not multiples you know an order
of magnitude less well over that so men
if you look at the total revenue of the
World Cup were paid seven percent that's
what the players got if you look at the
total revenue of the Women's World Cup
they were paid twenty percent so they
got almost three times as much as a
percentage of their total revenue that
the men got now women apparently want
400 percent of their revenue where's the
money gonna come from magic I guess or
maybe they're good they'll take it from
the men's team or something like that so
she's right the way if you want to build
up women's soccer which I don't
recommend you do but if that's something
you want to do the way you do it is you
buy season tickets you go to the games
you buy popcorn and Cracker Jack at the
games are there they probably have like
acai bowls and kombucha or something
whatever they sell at the stadium you
buy the jerseys you I don't know if
they've playing cards but you buy the
cards you just you give your money to
the sport and it becomes very big that's
how baseball went from being you know
relatively cheap endeavor in the 1940s
and 1950s now I go to a baseball game at
Yankee Stadium I have to take out a
mortgage on my car it's a big business
that's because people like it it's cuz
people really care about him now I don't
want to give the wrong impression here
that I like Megan Rapinoe or that I
think she's like a good figure in
American culture she is awful and she
exhibited in a video that has now gone
viral with her holding her trophy why
people really don't like her and why
people really don't like the whole ethos
around this women's soccer team here is
what Megan Rapinoe thinks about her win
is it she's so humble she's so thankful
to god she's so thankful to all the fans
know she says three words I deserve this
what do you what do you deserve you
deserve all of it everything you deserve
this oh it's like everything that's
wrong with feminism it's everything
that's wrong with this soccer team it's
everything that's wrong with leftism I
deserve this I'm entitled to this I'm so
great I'm so proud I have nothing to be
ashamed of I'm the best thing ever
this is pride I mean we've been talking
about pride obviously for the whole
month of Pride Month pretty soon it's
gonna be pride year this is pride and
people hate pride pride is a vice pride
is a sin it's ugly
nobody likes it we like humility it's
amazing to me that the left gets on
Donald Trump because Trump brags all the
time you know he puts his name on
everything says I'm the best president
ever he actually has been a really good
president he's got a lot to brag about
and he rarely misses an opportunity to
brag and the left says this is awful
this is terrible I hate this but I love
when Megan Rapinoe kicked a ball only a
little bit worse than a 14-year old boy
and she deserves everything she deserves
the the bottle of Veuve Cliquot
champagne she's drinking and she
deserves the statue that she's holding
in her hand you don't deserve it
none of us deserves anything frankly I
mean this is a major difference between
how conservatives tend to view the world
and how radicals and leftists and
progressives tend to view the world I
don't think I deserve anything I have I
have an amazing life everything that
I've ever gotten is an unmerited gift
from God and all the suffering I've
endured is nothing compared to the this
great joy of life that we have I mean
just to use a particular example I got a
show because I didn't write a book I
didn't write a book and then I published
it and it was called reasons to vote for
Democrats a comprehensive guide and it's
completely blank and then I got a show
for it if that's not the unmerited grace
of God I don't know what is if you have
an attitude of gratitude that's sending
a little cliche but it's real it's a
cliché for a reason if you have an
attitude of gratitude you're going to
a better time in life you're gonna be
more thankful for the people you have
the friends you have the love that you
feel the love of God your Creator food
is going to taste better cigars are
going to taste better
drinks are going to taste sweeter
because you don't deserve this you
didn't invent your life you were given
your life is a gift ultimately that's
what it comes down to you didn't choose
your parents you're you were given your
parents and this is true for every this
is true for people who have
disproportionate amounts of suffering
this is true of people who have relative
privilege I'm kind of agreeing with the
left in that I'll check my privilege but
I'm not I'm not upset about privilege
I'm not ashamed
I'm happy for privilege when we all have
privileges it's a wonderful thing but
she says I deserve it I'm entitled to it
and it's why she always comes off as
bitter and awful and it's why that whole
team is bitter and awful and and they
hate their country and you know she at
least hates her country and she she
disrespects the American flag and she
she has no sense of how unimportant she
is she has no sense of all the wonderful
gifts she's been given the god-given
talents and the the ability to develop
those talents and a country to support
her to send her abroad I mean it's just
just terrible and it's not only a
problem of women's soccer this is a
cultural disease that has spread
particularly on the left and you got to
just cut it off at the knees she doesn't
deserve it she doesn't deserve anything
and she's terrible and only when she
acknowledges that will she I think come
to appreciate all the wonderful gifts
she's been given now I have got some III
think actually pretty good news but it's
really ironic news out of the courts
President Trump has now been told he
can't block people on Twitter I didn't
even know the president Trump was
blocking people on Twitter I don't think
you should ever block people on Twitter
I think that's the opposite of what
Twitter is Twitter is all about open
exchange I've never blocked anybody I
don't intend to block anybody the this
court now this appeals court has come
out and said President Trump can't block
his critics on
Twitter because he sometimes breaks news
on Twitter and so this cuts off certain
Americans from hearing this news and he
sometimes uses it to conduct government
business so he just can't do it it's
unconstitutional it's illegal that's
wrong you can't do it the irony here is
that the left blocks people on Twitter
way more than the right does they
unfriend people on Facebook way more
than the right does they I mean I can't
tell you there are left wingers that
I've never interacted with ever once in
my life and they will preemptively block
me on Twitter because they're afraid
that I might say something to them or
something I mean that guy Carlos maza
the one who wants to censor all the
conservatives he blocked me in like two
seconds and he's blocked as far as I can
tell thousands and thousands of other
conservatives aoc blocks a lot of people
on Twitter I think now she's being sued
for it so what this ruling means is if
President Trump can't block people on
Twitter AOC can't block people on
Twitter either you know the left can
give it but the left can't take it and I
actually think this is a pretty good
ruling some conservatives are a little
upset that Trump is you know being
targeted and it is true they're going
after Trump because he's Trump but I'm
all for it I want open communication I
don't want to live in a world where
we're blocking each other and we're
siloing ourselves and we're censoring
each other speaking of more important
court cases though just a little heads
up we'll talk about this more in a later
date when it when it finally makes its
way up to the Supreme Court but getting
back to the main topic of today's show
talking about sex baby and gender there
is a hugely important court case that's
coming down the pike and it's headed for
the Supreme Court and it's called the
Harris Funeral Home case cases
officially are G and G are Harris
funeral homes incorporated vs. Equal
Employment Opportunity Commission and
this case is all about sex and gender
whether or not there's a difference
between sex and gender how we can even
understand or enforce the left's
difference between sex and gender it's
all about title seven which is sex
discrimination from employers that's
what title seven of the Civil Rights Act
covers and it involves an interpretation
of the protections of title seven so
basically in this case
you have a funeral home owner Thomas
Ross and he has a dress code for his
employees obviously it's a really touchy
business to be in you've got grieving
families you know you're around sadness
and grief and sorrow all day long and
you want to make sure you look
professional and you behave in a way
that is comforting and consoling to the
grieving families
so he says okay men have to wear a
jacket and tie I don't know whatever it
is and women have to dress in this
certain way nobody suggests that it's
wrong to say men have to dress one way
and women have to dress another way
nobody is arguing that that's wrong in
this case what they're arguing about
here is that one of Roth's employees at
the funeral home who is a man one day he
went on vacation he comes back and he
decided he's going to now start dressing
as a woman at least when he feels like
it maybe he doesn't dress like a woman
all the time but he's gonna dress like a
woman when he feels like it and Ross
said the owner he said you can't do that
it's not all about you buster it's about
these grieving families and if they see
a giant man with a beard wearing a dress
like the guy in that video you know
who's screaming at the employee at the
bodega and he says I am a woman
it's ma'am call me ma'am that that's
going to be distracting for grieving
families obviously that's the case now
the employee Sue's and this is gonna
make its way up to the Supreme Court the
question is does title 7 of the Civil
Rights Act say that employers can't
discriminate on the basis of sex which
is what we've always interpreted it to
mean or does it say that they can't
discriminate on the basis of gender
identity and what the left is gonna
argue in this case is that of course it
always included gender identity when the
Civil Rights Act was passed no one had
any idea what this gender identity thing
was this was not there was no no one
believed that there was a difference
between sex and gender but just imagine
how this if it were the case that a
gender that it protected gender identity
as well and so therefore the funeral
home guy has to let the funeral home
employee with a big big beard dress up
in a dress we're
gormless of what the grieving families 1
if that were the case how is that going
to be enforced what if one day he
decides to dress like a man and he says
well if my identity today as a man big
if you have no ability to to run your
business as you would like to run your
business but beyond that what the the
plaintiff in this case is arguing the
the man who wants to dress like a woman
is he says well the way you can enforce
it is if a guy can pass as a woman he
looks more like a woman then he can be
allowed to dress like a woman but if he
can't pass as a woman then he can dress
as a man that's a reasonable agreement
that's a compromise that is insane and
that is talk about the patriarchy talk
about going back to our Kane views of
sex you're now going to leave it up to
an employer to decide if a woman looks
womanly enough or too manly or a man
looks womanly enough or what are you
kidding me this is another irony of it
is as feminism has long broken down so
of boundaries and said look if a girl
wants to wear jeans and she doesn't want
to wear a dress that's okay doesn't make
her less of a woman little girl can be a
tomboy a little boy can play with dolls
now we're saying the opposite we're
saying women must look womanly they must
they must wear dresses they must and men
now I don't know they have to be Cowboys
they have to wear jeans or something
they want to have it both ways on this
issue but this makes no sense whatsoever
I'm hopeful that this will win at the
Supreme Court but this is the issue I
mean you have got this issue coming down
the Supreme Court and you could have
gender identity firmly implanted in
American law all the way down from the
Supreme Court the stakes are very high
we're gonna be following that case as we
will all of these crazy gender questions
in the meantime though we've run out of
time so get your mailbag questions and
I'll see you tomorrow
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knoll Joe
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys
over on the Matt Walsh show today the
largest teachers union in America has
just come out full throttle for abortion
radically pro-abortion I think it may be
time to start homeschooling I've always
thought that but I especially think it
now also there is an effort afoot to
stop the teens from vaping and those
efforts have gotten exceedingly corny
and we'll discuss the latest example and
finally is air conditioning sexist I
can't believe it's necessary to have
that conversation but it is so we will
today on the mat wall show